[موسيقى]
انتقل الى الدرعيه وجمعها في مكان واحد
كانت متفرقه يحكمها اخر اناس وايضا الفرع
الاخر يحكم القصيبه اخر فاستطاع محمد
يعتبر محمد ابو سعود اول ما نوحد اجزاء
الدرعيه هذا المشروع الوحدوي الاول
ولهذا هذا المشروع ترتب عليه ايضا اتصال
وتواصل ايضا اجتماعي وايضا لم هذه القرى
المتفرقه في الدرعيه
[موسيقى]
كتب ادهم بن دواسي الى محمد بن سعود ان
اهل الرياض قاموا ضدي فاريد ايضا هذه
القوه منك ان تقوم بايضا بدعم فتولى
الحقيقه محمد مسعود فارس الى بقياده اخيه
مشاري فاحكم السيطره على الرياض وجعل دهان
ابن دواس اميرا على الرياض
بسبب نصره محمد بن سعود لدهان بن دواس
تمكن من حكم الرياض لان محمد بن سعود ادرك
هناك خلافا سياسيا قبله في حكام الرياض
لان الحكام الرياض على الدعيه بالتالي
ايضا في منفوحه فتمكن بالتالي
[موسيقى]